(soft jazz music)
- If someone does a lame
joke, I laugh too much.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- You're a sweet guy.
- I don't wanna
make them feel bad.
- Oh, I wanna do just the opposite.
I want them to feel horrible.
- Wow.
(Jerry laughing)
- But doesn't it bother
you that they think
they're funny enough to make
a joke to make you laugh?
- But why shouldn't they?
- Because you've spent your
entire life in this craft,
in this world.
- But you're treating it
like an insult, and it's a compliment
that they would love you
to laugh at them because
they like you so much.
- Yes, because it would
make them think that
they're on the same level,
and they're not.
- But it's not like someone
going up to a doctor
and going, can I take your appendix out?
- Yes, it is!
- No, it's not!
- It is to me!
- We're not that important.
- Aren't we?
(Ricky cackling)